よろしくお願いします
これから我々は幸せになる心の働きと
それから不幸になる心の働きということについてお話しさせていただきます
基本的な全部内容は鈴木さん教えたと思いますから
また同じことを繰り返すとつまらなくなる可能性もありますけど
どうしようかと困っているんですけど
だいたい今日いらっしゃっている方々の
結構過半数ですか ヴィパッサナー瞑想ってどういうことかというご存知で
また実践した経験もある方々です
そういうところから話が始まります
ヴィパッサナー瞑想をすると
私たち大体このこれは瞑想かと
みんななんとなく疑ってみる一つの現象があるんですね
瞑想といえば 修行といえば
もう大変真剣に堂々たる姿でもうやるものではないかと思っていて
ヴィパッサナー瞑想の指導を受けたところで
まあ大変簡単で楽で 自分なりにやればいいと
何もしきたりもなく まあどんな方法でもいいようなことを言っているような感じがするんですね
それでなかなか納得いかなくて
瞑想自体もうまくいかないという結果もあるんですね
で ヴィパッサナー瞑想では我々はこう言うんですね
例えば歩くときは左足上げる
運ぶ 下ろす 右足を上げる
運ぶ 下ろすと ただそれだけ確認して歩いてくださいと
それを何のことかとみんな疑ってみるんです
体でも顔でも瞑想中掻きたくなっちゃったら掻きたい
掻きます 手を上げます
上げますと 触れましたと
掻きます 掻きますと 終わりました
手を元に戻りますと ゆっくり戻してみてくださいと
まあそういうふうなことは瞑想と言えるんですか？と
掃除 洗濯をする場合は
ちゃんとそれなりの言葉をかけてやってください
それはヴィパッサナー瞑想であると
私はもう散々嫌になるほど言ってるんですね
じゃあなんでこういうことを言いますかと
そういうことを言うのは一つのわけがあるんです
で たとえ我々の体が完全にこの心の命令で動いているんです
ちゃんと聞いてほしいんです
統一して 我々の体が心の命令で動いているんです
たとえ自分の指を動かそうとしたっても
動かしたいという気持ちなければ指は動かせません
動くことはできないんです
どんな微かな体の動きであろうか
それは私たちの意思で
そうしたいんだからしているんです
意思と言うんです これは仏教用語でチェタナと言うんです
普通の日本語で言えば意思ですね
何かをしたいという気持ち
それで体の動きを見ると
いろんな体の動きがあります
その動きをいろいろ分析して分けてみます
その中ではっきりと自分の意思でやっている行動とどうかなと感じる行動
二種類あるでしょうと思います
例えば歩く 何かを食べる
人とお話をする 座る 寝る
仕事をする 書く 掃除をする
そういうことをする場合は
自分の意思でそういうことをしているということはわかりますね
すごく簡単にわかるんです
歩く時は歩きたいんだから歩いているということはいくらかわかるんです
何かと何かしている場合は
それは自分がそうしたいんだから
その行動をしているとわかるんです
ですから ヴィパッサナー瞑想では
まずこのよくわかる行動から
意思を理解しやすいんだから
そうしてくださいと言っているんです
それでもう一つ行動があるんですね
我はまぶたを閉じたりする
呼吸したりする それで体の中にまたいろいろ動きはある
それから寝ていると 寝返りやらいろんな体の動きをしている
そういう問題は 私は前言ったことから考えると
かすかな行動も意思でやってますよと言うならば
じゃあどうやって寝返りしているんですかと
まあ瞑想みたいなものをしない時は
我々は呼吸しているということは全然気づいてないんです
じゃあどうやってそれをしているんですか？自分の心臓の動きはどうやって意思でやってるんですか？ということは出てくるんです
ですから 体の行動は二つに分けた方がやりやすい
一つは明確に自分の意思でやっている行動働き
二番目は自分の意思と関係なく
ただ自然的に体をやっている働き
行動 そこで仏教の立場から言うと
その両方も意思であるいは心でやらせているんです
両方 それで我々には心を理解できるんです
簡単に一つは心のある側面というのは自分でコントロールできるんです
歩く時はゆっくり歩こうか
速く歩こうかというのは自分で判断してコントロールできる
駅まで歩くとか十分かかるんだと
遅くなって七分しかないんだと
ああ 早く行かなくちゃと思って早く行くんですね
それで知り合いの人に出会うと会ったら
ああとかもうおはようございますやらこんにちはとか
どこお元気ですか？とかね
話をすると時間がなくなってしまっちゃうんですね
その場合はすぐ自分の意思で考えて
どうするべきかと ちょっと急いでますよとかね
遅くなったんだから走ってるよと
なんとか一言葉だけ言って
さっさと駅まで行くと
その場合は自分の行動を喋ることを考えること
それで体の行動は全部自分の意思でコントロールしているので
心のそういう部分があるんです
自分でコントロールできる働きがあるということなんです
早く歩くかゆっくり歩くか
たくさん食べるか もう食べ物は控えるか
めちゃくちゃ人と喋るか
言葉をコントロールするかと
そこら辺我々にコントロールできる部分があるんです
じゃあ二番目に入りますが
例えば心臓が弱い人がいると
心臓が弱い人が派手に心臓を鼓動させたら良くないんですね
それは命に関わるものなんです
じゃあその人にできますかね？じゃあ私の心臓が弱いんだから
いつでも安定な状態で一定した回数で心臓が動くようにしておきますと
ドキドキドキドキと早く動かしちゃったら
心臓に負担がかかってもう危ないんだと
というふうなコントロールできますか
それはなかなかできないんですね
呼吸にいたっても同じことなんですね
呼吸はちょっと置いておきましょう
で 例えば我々の腸が食べたものはちゃんと消化する
胃の働きも大体皆様知ってるでしょうね
心の状態によっていろいろ変化すると
すごい心配したり すごい心配することがいろんなあると
悩むことはいっぱいあると
胃が荒れてしまうと 腸の働きが混乱するんだということを皆様もう経験もある方々いるでしょうと思いますけど
知ってるんですね 胃下垂になったりとかね
まあそういうお医者さんがそう言うと
なるほど 自分の心によって胃の働きがおかしくなったと
腸が病気になったと分かりますけど
それから人がちょっとだけ食べたっても
すぐ太ってしまっちゃうとか
またある人はいくら食べても全く平気で
体がスマートのまんまでとかはあるんですね
そこで体が太るような傾向の人々が医学的に知ってますから
それを脂肪をあまり燃やさないで
どんどん皮膚の中でも蓄えておくんですね
一番いいのは もう食べた脂肪が吸収しないで体から出しちゃえば問題ないんですね
脂肪の吸収が控えれば
じゃあ腸の働きも心の働きでやってるならば
じゃあ自分にできますかね
それは じゃあ今日私はいっぱい美味しいものあるんだからいっぱい食べますけど
もう2日分も食べますけど
でも吸収するのは今日の分だけですと
それだけ吸収して消化して
残りは全部体から出しちゃって
スマートの体のまんまで健康な体のまんまでいますと思ってもできますかと
それは大体無理な話なんですね
いっぱい食べちゃったら全部体消化して
全部吸収して やっぱり脂肪として蓄えておいちゃうんですね
だから心の働きが働き 2つあると覚えておいてください
私たちにはなんとかコントロールできる働きと
どうも手に負えない 手の施しようもない働きが 2つあるんだと
それ 2つある ですから
わかりやすく言えば 自分の意思でコントロールできるところは
自分の幸福の方向へコントロールして管理しておけば
まあその分は幸福になります
それは我々言わなくても大体人々はやってることなんですね
例えば子供はすごく遊び遊ぶこと好きなんですけど
やっぱり子供も大人もまあそんなに遊びばっかりしてたらダメですよと
まあ嫌ですけど 勉強もしなくちゃいけないんだ
それでまあ子供はちゃんとそれを理解して
勉強もする 我々いろんなことを勉強したり
いろんな習い事を習ったりして
仕事をちゃんと覚えておいて
で 眠たいんだけど 夜仕事あるならば
まあ眠ることを控えて
仕事の勉強なんかしてコントロールするんですね
それで人間は幸福になるんです
勉強するべき時は勉強して
仕事をするべき時はちゃんと仕事をして
人と話をするべき時はちゃんと話をして
黙っている時は黙っているべき時はちゃんと黙っていて
そういうふうな行動をしていると
どんな人間でも結構幸福になってしまうんです
で その場合はどういう働きかというと
我々にコントロールできる心の側面
我々はちゃんといい方向へコントロールしているんです
だから勉強するか寝るかっていうのは自分の意思でコントロールできるんです
それで寝る 寝たいという気持ちもありますけど
あるいは他の漫画なんか読みたいという気持ちもあるんだけど
やっぱりそれを置いておいて
勉強しましょうということに決めちゃうんですね
それでその行動をする
そういうことうまくいけば問題ないんですね
いわゆるやるべきことはちゃんとやって終わると
自分の仕事をちゃんと果たすと
自分の将来 未来のことをちゃんと計画を立てて
その通りに考えて行動すると
そうするならば問題はないんです
それは心のコントロールできる
意識でコントロールできるところなんです
我々の意識ではなくて
意識で だけどそこら辺は別に宗教はもうお説かいのこと言わなくたっても
ごく普通な人間はよくご存知なことなんですね
スポーツマンになりたい人がいるならば
きちんと訓練をする よく食べて寝て食べて寝ても試合に出るということはありえないと
その人々は知っている
だから 苦労しながらでも
もうきついんだけど ちゃんと訓練しなくちゃいけないんだと思って
ちゃんとそれはやっています
それでいい選手になる
そういうふうな ごくわかりやすい幸福の世界
自分の意思の部分でコントロールして得られることはできます
それでも人生失敗する人々がいるんですね
例えば もう女性でお嫁に行ったんだと
そこで家庭のことはちゃんとするのは
一応伝統的な仕事だから
まあそれは失敗すると
家の面倒はちゃんと見られないんだと
料理のことはうまくできないと
弁当は作れないとか 朝早起きできないとか
あるいはみんなを出て行っちゃったら
もうすぐ酒でも飲んでもうダメになるとか
そういうケースもあるんですね
いわゆるもう家庭の中のことは失敗すると
それ女性の場合 男性の場合も同じく
もう会社に行って仕事をするのは普通ですけど
うまくいかないと 任せる仕事はもう結構失敗ばっかりしてしまうと
仲間とうまくいかなくなったりして
そこでもう仕事をクビになって
もう大変不幸になるとか
あるいは結構お金があったり
事業をやったりしたんだけど
まあ全部失敗して 家も恥ずかしくて家も出てホームレスになってしまうとか
ホームレスになっているのはほとんど男性でしょうし
それもみんな同じく この家庭のことを失敗して
あるいは大変不幸な人生にしている女性の方々と同じことで
よりもっとひどいですけど
ホームレスにまでなってしまうと
住む家もなくなっちゃったんですよ
それはごく普通な生き方
間違って失敗する人々
そこで問題は まあなんでしっかり考えて行動しないかっていうことなんですね
それはコントロールできるのに
仏教はあってもなくても
キリスト教はあってもなくても
自分の人生幸福になるぐらいのこと
自分で考えればわかるんだから
収入がなければ生きていられないということは
別に言わなかったらわかりませんよというならば
とんでもない話でしょうに
たまに子供はそういうことを言うんですね
自分が何かもう勉強を間違って忘れたりして
遊んで宿題を忘れたりして
そこで学校でもう恥ずかしい目になったら
うちに帰ってお母さんに文句を言うので
お母さんなんで思い出してくれなかったんですかとか
ちゃんとなんで宿題自分の本をカバンに入れてくれなかったんですかとかね
そういう話は大人も言うならばね
ちょっとおかしいし 私は子供にさえそういう話は言わせないんです
厳しく言うんです その場合は
自分のことを自分で責任持ってやれと言えませんと
私のところに国でなんですけど
いる子供たちはもう朝は大体もう寝たいのはわかりますけど
でも起こせません 自分で起こりなさい
ちゃんと起きなさいと
たまに子供たちもするんだから
すごく甘い顔をして 明日朝早く起こしてちょうだいねとか頼んだりはする
その場合はお互いにちゃんと約束したならば
向こう側はちゃんと言ったならば
朝はやっぱり起きられませんと
ですから起こしてくださいと言うならば
はい わかりましたと じゃあ起こしてあげますと
そういうのは回 回はやってあげますけど
その場合はちゃんとした約束だから
それはしょうがないんです
本人は自分の弱さに気づいて
それはちょっと今のうちは自分でコントロールできない
その時はちょっと助けてくださいと頼むことだから
それはしっかりした自分のコントロールなんですね
自分のことを責任自分で持っていることなんですね
ですから それは大人だけではなくて
子供だけではなくて 大人まで
我々は生きている間は
自分の責任を自分で持って
自分の幸福というものを自分で作っていかなくちゃいけないんです
そこら辺自分でできるんですね
大体皆様方 健康に大変興味ありますから
健康のためといえば何でもするし
どんな運動でもするし
どんなスポーツでもするし
その場合もやっぱりいろいろ話を聞いて
その通りに自分で一生懸命するんですね
なぜそうなさるかというと
やっぱり自分の健康を自分で作らなくちゃいけないんだと
私がもう私の体が悪くなったのはあなたのせいですよと
と言えませんだから たまに言うまあアホな人もいますけどね
親のせいですよとか 誰かのせいですよとかね
例えば自分の体が弱くなってきたならば
病弱になったなら それは自分のせいですけど
自分でちゃんと自分の体のコントロールしなくちゃいけない
そうすると健康的になる
そういうとこは我々はよく知ってる世界でコントロールできる部分
心の部分 ですから ここで私は言いたいのは
スポーツしたっても 健康食品食べても
きちんと仕事をしても
あるいはいい加減仕事を仕事をしたっても
それは自分の意思で 自分の心で考えてやっていることですということなんです
それに反対だというならば
じゃあ自分の意思に反して手を挙げてみてください
例えば手を結んでおきたい意思と気持ちとしては
それなのに手を挙げてみてください
挙げられますかと 全然挙げられませんよ
手を挙げる場合は 自分で手を挙げたいという気持ち
そこに働いてるんです
手を下ろす場合も 手を下ろしたいんだと
自分の意思の命令が入っていて
手を下ろしちゃうんです
ですから この意思というものはもうきちんと
もうそういうふうに行動していて
お風呂に入りたいと思っている人は
きちんとカバンを持って外へ出かけるということはもう絶対ありえないんだから
よっぽどの病気な人でなければ
よっぽど精神的にイカれてる人でない限りはそんなことはしません
痴呆の方々は別として
もう痴呆の方々にしても
決してこの変なことをやってるわけじゃないんです
例えば炊飯器に まあ大体女性の方が痴呆になっちゃったら
炊飯器に米入れて それを洗うことも何もなく
そのまんまコンセントに挿すとか
そういうことはありますけどね
じゃあもうおばあちゃんがもうちょっと痴呆になって困っちゃったなと我々思うんだけど
本人は別におかしい行動をしているわけじゃないんです
自分のもう頭の脳細胞のね
いろいろ死んでいるんだから
もうちゃんとコントロールできないし
でも生きている部分でずっとやっていたことだから
じゃあご飯を炊かなくちゃいけないんだと
それ出てくるし でも米をちゃんと洗って適量な水を入れなくちゃいけないという部分は働いてない
あるいはその瞬間で 米を入れた瞬間でコンセントを挿すことに頭が行くかもしれません
それで他のことに自分の意識が行ってしまっちゃう
だからそこら辺 ちょっとコントロールはないだけで
そのコントロールしてくれる部分
全部総合して このもう中央的に全部管理してくれるいろんな脳細胞の回路は壊れていることだから
そうなっているんであって
その場合も痴呆になっている人々さえ
やることはちゃんと自分の意思でやってるんです
それは忘れるだけの問題ですけどね
そういうことで よくヴィパッサナー瞑想の経験ある方々はよく理解してほしいんです
たとえ小さなもう指の動きでも
瞑想してるとちょっと体を動かしたりするでしょうに
ちょっと痛くなってくるとすぐ体を動かしてしまう
そういうことは全部自分で意思で考えてしているものなんです
だから私たちは社会的に幸福になったと
あるいは不幸になったと
大変自分が混乱だらけでも困ってるんだと
それいろいろ言うならば
それは全て自分の心が自分の意思で自分がやっていることになるんです
判決は 分かりやすく言えば
自分のおかげか自分のせいか
どっちかなんですね じゃあそこら辺は問題ない
でも問題ありきね なぜならば
それだったら人間誰であろうが幸福になりたいと
成功したいと 明るく清らかで生きていきたいというのは
まあごく普通な気持ちなんです
お釈迦様おっしゃるのは
全ての生命が幸福になりたいと思ってるんだと
スカカーマというパーリ語の言葉がございまして
一応あの スカカーマニブータニ
それは法句経で出てくる偈文
文句ですけど まあいろんなところにいろんな言葉が出てきます
ブータニっていうのは
衆生 生きとし生けるものは
スカカーマニ 幸福を願ってるんだと
幸福を好んでるんだと
いわゆる幸福を好む性質の生きとし生けるものというふうなことなんです
ですから 生命 人間だけではなくて
生命は全てみんな自分の幸福を願っているんです
希望しているんです それで我々にはいろいろ幸福があるんです
そのその人の幸福論は違うし
百人いれば百人の幸福論が出てくるし
それで人間の幸福と動物の幸福はまた違うし
それはそれで別に気にする必要はないんです
私が幸福だと思うことは
あなた方にとっても幸福だよというふうなことは
まあおかしな話と思います
ですから それはそれで構いませんだけど
とにかく自分で考えた何か幸福を願ってはいるんです
そこで私は分かりやすく言うのは
あなたはそんなに幸福になりたけりゃなりなさいと
なんでいちいち文句言ってるんですかと
というわかりやすい言葉なんです
幸福になりたいんですかと
なりたいんじゃなってくださいと
そう言ったらなかなか納得してくれませんだけど
理論はそういうものなんです
幸福になりたいならば
自分のその幸福になりたいと意思で行動するならば
幸福になるのはごく普通な当たり前の論理なんです
で それでこの今日の話の次のポイントに行こうと思ってるんです
ポイントはこういうことなんです
じゃあ生命はすべてことごとくみんな幸福になりたいという希望はある
が みんな幸福になるわけじゃない
なぜ一部の生命が不幸で
一部の生命が幸福で 一部はもう半分半分で幸福でもあるし
不幸でもあるし まあ中途半端でわからないと
幸福か不幸かと あれは何ですかと
もし生命がそんなに幸福を願っているならば
幸福になるはずであると
生命は自分の意思で行動しているでしょう
合理的に考えましょう
数学的に 生命は自分の意思で行動している
生命の意思は幸福になることであると
そうであるならば 行動する生命はみんな幸福になるはずです
でしょ そういう単純な計算で
そういう答えが出てくるんです
自分の意思で行動すると
その同じ結果を得られますから
例を出すならば おせんべいを一つ持って
それ食べたいと思う人は口に入れるんです
決して鼻の穴に差し込もうと思わないんです
鼻の穴も体の中だから
それでいいんじゃないかと
そういう人はいないんです
せんべいをおいしく食べて楽しみたいと思う人は
きちんと自分の意思で
それは口に入れるべきものですとちゃんと知っていて
口で噛むべきものですと
で 噛んで食べて飲み込んで
その幸福を味わう その場合
わかりやすくせんべいを食べて楽しみたいという幸福論があって
ちゃんとそれを実行する
もし全ての生命が幸福というものは願っているならば
それは意思であるならば
生命がどんな行動をしても
それは幸福につなぐ幸福をもたらす行動であるはずなんです
そうすると宗教の仕事はなくなりますけど
全ての生命は幸福になるんです
じゃあなんでならないかと繰り返して言いましたけど
ということは 次のポイントで説明いたします
なぜならないかと で 我々は自分の意思で行動することはするんだけど
大変わかりやすいことがあります
で この これは仏教用語でよく使う言葉で
このなまけということがあるんですね
なまける なまけ で 一つ新しいパーリ語の言葉を紹介しますけど
アラシアン アラシアンというのはもう怠けって意味なんです
それやったらもう何も実現できないんだとお釈迦様はしっかりと教えているんです
人間はダメになる 生命はダメになる
原因一つとして もうアラシアン
怠ける すごいわかりやすいんですね
もう なんで人間が 子供
若い人々はよく勉強しないかというと
どこかで怠けているとか
なんで奥様が家庭の仕事はちゃんとうまくしてないかというと
もう結構怠けていると
なんで会社仕事うまくいってないかというと
そこでも結構怠けているということは出てくるんです
そうすると 自分の行動はうまくいかない
わかりやすい そう言っても
よく言うのは いや 我々は別に怠けたくないんだと
怠けているわけじゃないんだと
しっかり頑張っているんだと
それでもうまくいかないんだと言うんです
そうするどうしますかね
まあ堂々と怠けている人であるならば
もうわかりやすくて もう怠けているんだと
でも大体九十パーセントの方々は
冗談じゃないんだと 失礼なことを言うなと
私たちはもう朝から晩まで忙しくて暇がなく頑張っているんではないかと言うんです
それはどういうことかというと
怠けをごまかしているんです
よくあることで この頑張りますと
頑張ってますと その怠ける人のこのずるいところがありまして
よく頑張っちゃうんです
それを見抜くことをなかなかできないんです
で 結果でわかります よく頑張ったところでいい結果が出たら怠けてはないと
頑張っても結果が悪いというならば
まあちょっとおかしいと
私は昔教えている時は
このある若い沙弥が坊主がいて
いつ見ても いつでも本を読んでいるんです
この教科書なんかはもういつでも手にあります
他の若い坊主たちが遊ぶはいたずらするはもううるさくても
いくら言っても言うことを聞かない
勉強でもちょっとしたらどうですかとか
まあ怒りっぱなしで二十四時間いなくちゃいけないんですね
普通の家庭では大変です
まあいっぱいいるんだから
それまた一番悪い年のもう一番いたずらする男の子
その年の男の子 男の子ばっかりだから
でも いくら遊んでいても
大体みんなよく勉強できて
まあいい成果出しますけど
この特別にその人は全然遊ぶこともない
みんな大体寝ているなと思っている時間でも
ちょっと部屋を覗いてみたら
もう本を開けて読んでいるんですね
いくら本を読んでも 全然十点二十点取るのはもうものすごいもう精いっぱいで
それも私はもう余分に慈悲であげるものなんです
二十点ぐらいでも そうでない答案はそのままもう捨てたくなるほどなんです
あれどういうことですかね
別に脳に障害があるわけじゃ
それだったら出家させませんだから
何も問題ないんです 家庭の問題とかあるわけじゃないし
他の苦労しているわけでもなんでもないし
全部環境は揃ってあげているし
本人もすごい健康な体で健康な頭で問題ないんです
それで普通のガキたちよりはもう十倍以上
もう本から手を離さないんですね
それでもいい結果が出てこない
それも私はそのケースを見て
やっぱりこれは正真正銘の怠けだと
あのいつでもふざけて遊んでもいたずらばっかりやっている人々は怠けてないんです
なぜかというと もうずっと遊んでいたずらして
もうもう勘解由怒られてるんだから
その上宿題もやってないと思っちゃったら
もうとんでもないことになるの知ってるんだから
きちんとそれもやるんです
人のものを盗んででも書いてくれるんです
そこで怠けてないんですね
遊びたいという気持ちもあるんだから
まあ遊んで その分は後で頑張っても怒られるんだから
勉強もするとか たまに授業に来るともう体も汗びっちゃびちゃで
テキストも全部濡れて
向こうの紙の質もそんなに良くないんだからもう大変ですけど
まあそれでもまあ自分の勉強ぐらいまあちゃんとやってるっていうことはあるし
そこでこのずっと勉強する人とこの話なんですけど
本当は怠けてるんですね
本当のところはこの言うことは理解しようとしない
私たちは一生懸命しゃべるんだけど
教室で じっと聞いてるんだけど
理解しようとしないんですね
その代わりにそれをごまかす
他の子供たちは勉強しながら
隣の人に何かでも鉛筆でも刺してしまっちゃうし
足で蹴ったりするし そうすると私たちは怒るし
それでしっかり勉強しろと
話を聞けと言うでしょ
そう言われないように
叱られないように よく聞いてるんだと先生に褒めて褒めてもらうように
じっと話を聞いてる ただ聞いてる格好をつけてるだけ
頑張ってるだけ 頭に内容は入らない
それで勉強終わったら
その時からずっとテキストはもう手から離せません
ちゃんと読んではいるんだけど
やっぱり頭には入らない
よく勉強しているんだと
その自分をごまかしている
それ自分の心の怠けをごまかしている
それで勉強できなかったんです
もしその今例に出した人が一応読んでみたんだけど
さっぱりわからないんだと
授業を聞いたっても全然わからないんだと
ダメだと覚悟を決めて私にでも言ってくれたならば
私は勉強をやめますと
ダメだと 勉強をずっとやってみたんだけど
全く進歩はないんだと
言ってくれたならば 僕は何か他の方法は見つかるんですね
その人のために それだったら
私にとってはその人のなぜ脳細胞が動かないかと
その原因を探れますから
あるいはどうしてもテキストのような
そういう勉強下手だったら
他のやることはいっぱいありますから
それ何か道を教えられることできましたけど
それはできなかったし
勉強ばっかりしてるんだから
もう手に負えないんですね
それで我々のどんな社会でも
よく頑張る人はいるんです
一生懸命頑張ってしまっちゃう
でも結果はむちゃくちゃです
そうすると気をつけてください
自分がただ自分を騙すために体を壊すところまで頑張っても
結果が悪いんだったら
自分が怠けているんだと
どこかで自分をごまかしているんだと
例えば 会社で何かレポートを書けと命令されたと
それで自分が 1週間徹夜してレポートを書いたと
書いたレポートを持って行ったところで
向こうはもうポイとこれダメですよと捨てたんだと
はっきり読もうともしないで
そういう結果になったならば
この上司に怒るのではなくて
自分がどこかでおかしいんじゃないかと
と思ってください ただ
ご苦労さんでものを終わった
恋しくないんです ああ
ご苦労様でしたと 物は役に立ちませんと
そのよく見られるこの頑張るという概念でよく見られる性格は
もうかなりこの人間持っている怠け癖を隠すために
ごまかすために使っているんです
ですから まあ要は結果なんですね
何時間頑張るかということじゃないので
徹夜したかしなかったかということじゃないんです
そこら辺 文化的な差があるかもしれませんだけど
私たちはやっぱり結果で見るんですね
例えばレポートを書こうと思って徹夜しなくなっても
まあ 朝でも 1時間ぐらい早く起きてさささっと書いて持って行ったならば
それでも向こうでOKと言うならば
それでOKですから ですから
そういう風にこのもういい結果というか
このきちんと行動する人が
あのちゃんと自分の仕事
自分目指す結果を得られるようにするんです
例えば 上司がどうしても自分を叱りたくているならば
その人のことを勉強して
どんな好みの人かと その人を見ただけで驚くほどのレポートをなんとかしてもう書けますよ
私はもう学問的な世界のこと知ってますから
何にも内容ないにも関わらず
すごい学問的に研究して研究して書いたような形で書けますよ
簡単に で まあそういう論文やらいっぱいもあるし
見ると驚くんですね もうすごいいい本だな
すごいいい研究だなと
もう結局何も研究してない
何も発見してないということはあるんです
たまに私も人を騙す時あるんです
まあそういう形やら そんなことばっかり気にして
内容に興味がないとか
で あ この人はそんなに頭が鋭くないんだと
ただ形だけ見てるんだ
すっごい綺麗な形で何か書いてあげたりする
それすごく褒めてくれるんだけど
僕の頭の中でバカ野郎という感じなんですね
ただあなたを騙してあげただけで
そんなものはレポートでも何でもないんだという気持ちなんですけど
やってみたらそういうこともできるし
ですから 悪いことをしてくださいということではなくて
自分に対してはいい結果出せるようにするならば
自分が幸福になる それで頑張っているにも関わらず
なぜ幸福にならないかというと
一番わかりやすく言えるのは
このアーラシヤンという怠け
それ次の問題は このスカーマーニ
我々は幸福になりたいんだけど
心の中にこのいつでも常に離れないような性格なんですね
アーラシヤンという怠けっていうのは
私にも皆様にも 他の方々にも
誰にでもあるんです これもう心の現れる時と同時に生まれる一つの欠陥なんです
怠けがない人はない 生命は一人もいません
一人もいません 心は我々はこの 2つの方向に引っ張っているんです
幸福になりたい だから頑張れと
いえ 怠ければすごい楽しいで楽ですよと
怠けでじっとしたら楽しくて楽ですよというふうに
この両側に引っ張られてるんですね
自分がどちらに惹かれるかということなんです
だから人間は幸福になりたければ
常に励まなくちゃいけないんですね
この励むという言葉 このパーリ語だったらもうたくさんの言葉がありますから
どんな言葉を紹介した方がいいかわかりませんだけど
一応一つだけ紹介します
励む これの反対の言葉
まあこれはよく使う言葉です
読み方はヴィリヤン ヴィリヤン
それはこのアーラシヤンの正反対
ですから 幸福になりたければこう思ってください
自分の心に生まれつき大変な毒みたいな
この怠けというものをもう住みているんだと
別に育てなくてもそれあるんだと
それにこのアーラシヤンというもうウイルスですか
もう何か入ってるんですね
それに自分が新しくヴィリヤンという薬を飲ませてあげなくちゃいけない
アンチウイルスをあげなくちゃいけないんです
それあげると アーラシヤンというものは消えちゃうんです
いわゆるヴィリヤンというのは励むこと
努力すること 精進すること
ですから 我々は強引に励んで努力しなくちゃいけないんです
励んで努力すると アーラシヤンという怠けが消えちゃうんです
それもこの形の問題ではないんです
朝から晩まで頑張ってるんだと思っても
それは外を外を見て 社会を見て自分がごまかしていることだけだから
この私は今日ここで喋っているのは心の問題
人からあなたえらい怠け者ではないかと言われても構いません
自分が 自分が本当に頑張っているならば
会社でもずっとよく仕事をしているんだとみんなにもう思われるために
いろいろバカなことをやらなくたっても
自分の仕事をきちんとやって
残りの時間でふざけて遊んだっても
それは私は構いませんと思っているんです
怒られたっても別にもう平気で仕事をしているんだから
ですから 私たちは何か形だけ取っているんですね
ずっともう会社でいる
いていればいいとか 仕事終わったらいる必要ないんです
堂々と外に出て他のことでもやればいい
勉強でもすればいいし
ですから まあそれは社会現象で
みんなと一緒にいるとかね
もう遅くまで仕事するならば
自分もずっと遅くまでいると
それで新しい勉強もできなくなっちゃいますけど
まあそれはそれで とにかく言いたがっているのは
そんな社会話ではなくて
このただ見えで 表で社会に向けて見せる
努力しているんだ 頑張っているんだということではなくて
心のエネルギーなんですね
心の中で怠けたい怠けたいという気持ちを抑えて努力するという
この注射を打って それで努力して
その分うまくいっちゃうんです
そこでその  1回 またこれも一つ覚えてほしいんです
このウイルスは風邪ウイルスと同じなんです
あの普通のウイルスっていうのは
このアンチボディという
何でしたっけ あれは日本語で
抗体じゃなくて この体の中に生まれるもの
抗体 抗体が生まれたらもう一生その病気にかからないということはあるんだけど
残念ながら 例えば風邪のウイルスはそうじゃないでしょ
一回引いてもまだ引く
まだ引く まだ引くと なぜならば
風邪のウイルスが自分の形を変えちゃうんですね
いつでも 形を変えちゃいますから
しょうがなくまた風邪引いてしまっちゃうんです
それでまた 3日4日で治りますけど
また風邪引いてしまっちゃう
そんなようなウイルスなんです
このアラスヤンという怠けというウイルスが
一回ウィリアムという薬で抑えても
その場では治ります また形を変えてまた現れる
そうするとまた新しいウィリアムという精進という
注射を打たなくちゃいけないんです
それでうまくいく そういうことなんです
ということは 例えば あの
まあ努力して頑張って何か成功しましたと
成功した瞬間には 私にはもうやれば何でもできるんだと思ってしまうし
それと同時になんか余計な自信ですか
余計な自信ついちゃって
自分にはできるんだと物事見えなくなっちゃうんですね
それは怠けなんです 自分心を安心させてあげるんです
あの仕事うまくいったんだから
自分にできそうと この安心させてあげて
これは怠けなんです アラスヤンなんです
それで次の仕事にかかる
その時から前の仕事ではすごい真剣で
もうものすごい丁寧に頑張ってやったのに
まあ自分だったら成功するぞという過剰自信があるんだから
大失敗してしまっちゃうんです
それよくあることなんです
あの若い人々の中にもあるんです
ある試験はものすごく抜群に合格すると
次の試験はもうダメになってしまう
なぜかというと 一つはものすごくうまくいっちゃったんだから
自分だったらできるんだと過剰自信つけちゃって
それから怠け怠けがまた働き出しちゃうんです
心っていうのはややこしいもんですよ
それで一応時間はそんなにないんですから
この 2つを覚えておいてください
我々のこの世俗的な 社会的な幸福
幸福な家庭 収入のある生活
余裕 ゆとりのある人生
健康な体 それからものすごい平和的な社会環境とか
そういうぐらいのものしか人間考えてないんだけど
幸福といったっても それぐらいのことはこういう意思で自分でもうすぐ簡単にできますよ
成功することは で なんでできないのかというと
このアーラシヤンという怠けるという大変なこの悪いエネルギー
いわゆるこのネガティブエネルギー
心の働きを鈍くするエネルギー
働いてます この科学の世界でよくあるんですね
例えば化学反応を遅くする何か入れておく
あるいは化学反応を速くする何か入れておくとか
それ特定な名前があると思いますけど
僕はそのことは知りませんですけど
触媒 そういう触媒というものはものなんですね
で アーラシヤン入っちゃったらもうどんどんこの結果がもう出てこないように遅くなって遅くなってとか
あるいは結果が全くなるなっちゃうとか
ウィリヤンというものを入れちゃったらちゃんと行動してその結果が得られる
そういう心の 2つの働きが覚えておいて
その 2つも自分の意思でコントロールできる
怠けるか努力するかっていうのは自分でできるものなんです
お祈りして得られるものじゃないんです
自分でやらなくちゃいけないんです
じゃあ それからこの この 2つほど大きくはないんだけど
次に我々のこの生き方
幸福でなく不幸にするのは
次のいろいろ心の感情いっぱいあります
ネガティブエネルギーは
今日はずっと片っ端から紹介しようと思っちゃったんだけど
みんな寝るでしょうね
そんなこと言うと だから 1つ2つしか紹介できない
で あの 今日 4つ書きましたけど
それはこのアビダンマ論から取った4つで
経典から取ったものではないんです
経典になるともっともっと詳しくて
もっと具体的ですけど
まあ一応ちょっとこれあまりにもこの心理学っぽくて
ちょっと実践的でなくなっちゃうかもしれません
1番はドーサと書いたんですけど
ドーサ ドーサっていうのは怒りなんですね
怒り  2番目はイッサと読むんです
これ このアはちょっとイッサ伸ばして読むんです
イッサっていうのはこの嫉妬
3番目はマッチャリーヤ
マッチャリーヤっていうのは物惜しみという物惜しみと言うんですかね
ケチなせい ケチというか
物惜しみというふうな言葉で訳していますけど
惜しみ 物惜しみ まあケチでもいいんです 3
番目  4番目は後悔 後悔っていうのはこの何でしたっけ
このまあ後悔するという
なんか悪いことしちゃったら自分が後悔するでしょ
その後悔 そういうのも心のものすごい巨大なネガティブエネルギーなんです
この 1番目に行きます
説明 ドーサっていうのは怒りであって
この怒りというものは
この 自分の目の前にあるものに対して
自分がすごく反対的な態度をとるんです
自分出会った現象は嫌だと
これすごい丁寧に聞かないとなんかもうわからなくなっちゃうんです
これ心の世界だから 僕はもうそう簡単にいい加減に喋ってるようなものなんです
すごい難しいことなんです
で 我々は自分の出会ういろんなものあるんですね
目で見られるものやら
耳で聞くものやら まあそんな話に行かなくたっても
まあ家庭やら会社やら社会やら
まあ私たちは毎日読む本やら見るテレビやら聞くラジオやら
いろんなものに出会ってるんですね
それから頭でいろんなことを考えるでしょ
それも我々は外と出会うことなんです
仏教から言えば 頭でいろんなことを考える時でも
私がいて考えてるんだから
外に出会っていることなんです
こういう自分という存在が外に出会うたびに
その出会ったものに対して
それは嫌だと 思う気持ち
怒りなの それを厳密的な定義なんですけど
で 心のことだから 我々は出会うもの
まあわかりやすく言えば対象という仏教用語なんですけど
対象について それは嫌だと
いわゆる拒絶反応みたいなものが起こっちゃう
何か見る 見たところでそれは見たくないんだと気持ちが生まれる
それは怒りです それでわからないと思うならば
もし人が自分に何か言う
その言われているものは聞きたくない
それ自分が聞きたくないものは
相手がすっと言ってる
私たちはどうするの？その場合は
すごく怒るでしょうね
そういうことなんです
自分に出会う対象に対して
それには会いたくないと心からこの拒絶
拒絶する感情が生まれる
拒絶というんですか 拒否する感情が生まれる
普通に怒りというのはそういうものなんです
それ大きくなったら いわゆる破壊的な感情が生まれる
破壊的になる で 物事を壊したくなる
批判したくなる 文句言いたくなる
説教したくなる こうではないんです
こうするべきではない
ああするべきではないとかね
えらいこの善悪を基準つけて
そればっかし どんなものについてあっても
あなたの食べ方悪いんだ
喋り方が悪いんだ 服の着方が悪いんだとか
座り方が悪いんだとか
それ私たちには理解できない
自分たちが本当にいいことをしているんだと思ってますけどね
やっぱりその心の怒りのエネルギーでそうやってるんです
じゃあ厳密な説明に入りますけど
もし人の心にこの怒りという動作というネガティブエネルギーが生まれちゃったら
その人は自分に出会う対象について拒否する反応が起こる
それで成功しますか？人間は幸福になるんですか？会った人を拒否するんだから
自分に出会った仕事も拒否するんだから
会社の仲間を否定するんだから
うちの中にいたっても
うちのメンバーたちをも否定する気持ちを持ってるんだから
決して成功とか幸福っていうのは全くありえないんです
不幸になってしまうんです
そういう性格の人々がいるんです
怒りの性格を持っていて
激しい性格を持っていて
物事を批判したり 厳しく善悪判断をしたりして
何も得られないんです
例えば会社に行って いつでも厳密にこれはこうするべきです
あれはああするべきです
ああだこうだと決める人は
決めつける人はいつでもみんなにも嫌な人だと思われるし
成功しない この人はすごい文字通りに仕事をするんだからといって成功するわけは絶対ないんです
そんなにキビキビと文字通りに仕事をしているんだから
必ず幸福になるだろうと
こんなことはない そこにあるのは怒りなの
それは理解しないんです
例えば会社に八時に入らなくちゃいけないと思ったら
まあぴったし八時に入るとか
そんなことやったっても
会社にとってはどうでもいいことで
あるいは人が八十分とか一本で来たら
あんたはもう遅刻したんではないかとか
たまにこの学校にもまあいるんです
自分の国のことなんですけど
先生たちは学校に行く時間が決まってあって
その時間に自分が何時間何時に来たかと
ちゃんと記録しておかなくちゃいけないんですね
それでまあ十分七分ぐらい遅れると
もう校長ですか 彼が全部そこで赤い線で引いて
それで終わりにするんです
それから十分遅れてくる人やら
十五分 十一分 十三分遅れてくる人々は
それ後から自分の名前を入れておかなくちゃいけない
それでもうすぐもう遅刻したんだということは
もうものすごい明確にも記録的に残しちゃうんですね
あんなもんで学校うまくいけるかと
僕は全然うまくいかないと思いますよ
あれは怒りしか何もないんだから
他の結構いろんな先生たちと話したことありますけど
他のもううまくみんな仲良くワイワイとやってる学校の教頭と話してみたら
まあみんな本当にもうお坊さんも怠けてね
もう時間に学校にも来ないし
まあそれはもう怒ったって意味がないんだから
私は一応もう三十分ぐらい待ってから自分のサインをつけるんだと
向こうは書いてサインしなくちゃいけないんですね
来た時間自分で書いて
ですから 私はこの三十分ぐらい待って
それからもうサインするんだと
あるいはもう遅く来る人々のために二
三行ぐらい置いといてサインするんだと
その場合は別に遅刻してはしてもいいということではないんです
そこでやっぱり人々のことをいくらか大目に見てあげる優しい心
そこにあるんですね それあまりひどくなっちゃったら
ごまかす 騙すことになりますけどね
政府のお金をもう一時間二時間も遅れてきて
ちゃんと仕事したようなことになります
そこまでは言ったら悪いんだけど
そうじゃなくて いくらかそこら辺大目に見てあげる
でもこの厳密すぎの人々は
本当は厳密すぎかすぎでもなく
完璧主義でもなく ただの怒りの性格を持っていて
反対したい 拒否したいという気持ちがある
大体この世直ししようと思っている人々の中でよくある現象なんです
社会を良くしようとか
言って そんなにいるならば良くしてくれるんだけど
結局批判ばっかりしてるんですね
あれが悪い これが悪いとか
その場合も そういう人々の行動から全然社会良くならないのは
やっぱりもともと怒りの気持ちを持ってるんですね
それでうまくいかない
そこでまあ論理的にお話ししますけど
私たちは見るもの 聞くもの
味わうもの 嗅ぐもの 考えるもの
触るもの 触れるもの なんだかんだにすぎても
まあちょっと嫌という気持ちが生まれるならば
拒否したい気持ち 気持ちが生まれるならば
幸福にはもう決してならないんです
例えば この椅子に座ったところで
これちょっと小さすぎじゃないかと思っちゃったら
そこに怒りが働いている可能性あるんです
あるいは大きい机を持ってきたら
こんなちょっと大きいすぎでしょうと
あるいはこっち クッションのついた机を持ってきたら
このクッションのついた机に座って
ここでもう話すことはできないんではないかと
落するとこじゃないんだと
あるいはクッション何もついてない硬い椅子を持ってきたら
そんな硬い椅子に長い時間座って
もうしゃべることはできませんと
というふうな性格なんです
ご飯作ったら ご飯はちょっともう今日は硬いんではないかと
今日はちょっとご飯が柔らかいんだと
ちょっと柔らかすぎじゃないのと
塩入れすぎだと 塩はもうちょっと入れてないんだと
何かこのミスだけ見つかっちゃうんですね
そこでうまい具合に世の中のことを見ると
そういう欠陥というのはいくらでも探すとあるんです
いくらでもあるんです
このテレビドラマでしか僕は日本の家庭は知りませんだけど
このそういうもうお嫁さんをいじめるこの姑さんのいろいろことを
ドラマだから別にからどうでもいいんだけども
で この何て言いますか
タオルとかね 洗って畳むでしょ
畳む場合はちゃんと何センチでたためなくちゃいけないかと
姑さんに決められて それでお嫁さんがちゃんとテープを持ってきちんとタオルをなんで幅が大きいと
といってもちゃんと整理してよってふうな
ドラマですけど だからその場合は何をちゃんとそういう
全くその通りではなくたっても
もう姑 お嫁さんがちゃんと拭いたところで
自分で指でこうやって見て
こう見たりするならばね
それは 欠陥を探査としてるだけなんですね
そこにあるのはただの怒りの性格だけ
それで当然その家庭は不幸になるでしょ
別に他の幽霊なんか憑いていなくたっても
もうそこに不幸になるんです
でも 姑さんもそれ知りません
姑さんには いえ 私はしっかりお嫁さんにも仕事を教えてるんだと
本人はそう誤解していて
でも 我々にはこの世の中で何を見たっても
探そうとするならば いくらでも見つかるんです
この部屋を掃除してくださいと言われたところで
もう厳密に隅から隅まで掃除したっても
どこかでも自分忘れたところあるんです
あるいはそれはちゃんと雑巾で拭いても
その人はすごい綺麗な指でも
こうやってこうやってやってみると
指の中に何か埃が溜まってるというところ
どうせあるんです ですから
もし怒りの性質あったら
もう大変なことで 世の中の幸福な世界見えない
悪いところだけ見える
そういう人々はもうどう頑張っても幸福にならない
なぜならば 自分に会う人とも敵に回していますから
自分聞き 聞く音についてもう敵に回しているんだから
どこかに音楽を聴きに行ったっても
やっぱり音は強すぎですよと
みんなワイワイと踊っているんだから
あまりうまく聞こえませんとか
でもレコード聴いた 聴いたとこと比べると
この生の演奏はあまり良くないんだとかね
今日は歌手が疲れていて
それほど綺麗な声は出ませんとか
言えるならばいくらでも言えますよ
だからせっかく楽しもうと思ったところ
楽しめないんです 結婚してもいい家庭を作ることはできない
会社に行ってもいい仕事することはできない
だから もし我々の性格の中で
なんか自分が偉くなった気持ちになっているならば
人の欠陥だけ見るような自分の世界あるならば
これはもうすぐ すぐ今直さなくちゃいけないんです
そうでなきゃもうどうしようもないんです
それの反対の性格っていうのは
やっぱりいい いいところを見ることなんです
この怒りの反対の言葉は
まあ即語で言えば愛なんですね
優しい心 慈しみの心なんですね
生命というのはどうせ不完全だから
完璧なものはありっこはないんだから
まあどうせどこかどこかで間違っているところはあるでしょうと
誰一人も完全なものは作りませんし
やりませんし それに怒ろうと思っちゃったら
もう生きていられないんだから
それで怒りが生まれてくると
体からもう体も変化して
強烈に体を壊れてしまうんですね
その心が体を動かす 手を上げたい時は手を上げる
例えば 私は人の手を持って自分が上げる場合はかなり重いんです
例えば 私は人の足を持って
あんた横になってくださいと
私はその人の足を四十回上げたり下げたりする
これ疲れますよ かなり足は重いんだから
あるいは人を運んでおんぶして百メートル行く
これ腰が痛くなるんで
その場合は 結構重いんです
でも意志が入ったらどうですか
私はその人に自分が足を二十回
あるいは四十回上げたり下げたりしてくださいと
全然疲れません その人は
自分がまあ百メートル
じゃあ二百メートル歩いてみてください
二百メートル歩いたって何のこともないんです
ということは 意志が入っちゃったら
この重い体は軽くなって動くということなんです
私は人の手を上げたり下げたりすると
これ結構重くてしょうがないんです
その本人が上げたり下げたりするのは何のこともなく軽いんです
重さがないんです この足を上げます
下げますという時でも
足を上げますと気持ちが入った瞬間に足が軽くなっていく
簡単に運ぶ 簡単におろせる
下ろしますと思った途端に足にすごい力がつけてしまう
重くなってしまう それから右足を上げますというと
右足が軽くなってしまう
それを簡単に理解できることですから
この意志が生まれると
体の物質は全部変化するんだというのが仏教の教えなんです
これは冗談で捨てる話じゃないんです
我々の気持ち次第に 我々の体はものすごく強烈に変化していくのです
だから怒ったら怒りにふさわしい体が生まれる
慈しみの心を作ったら
慈しみにふさわしい体が出来上がる
ですから もうお医者さんもよく言っていることの結果は出てくるんです
脳から体から細胞からいろんな悪い毒物質
体に毒の化学物質をいっぱい作って体は壊していただきますということになるのです
怒った瞬間に体中この毒がもう循環
瞬間に 電気エネルギーみたいな
ものすごい速さで動くんです
それ続ければもうめちゃくちゃ体壊れてしまうんです
腎臓も心臓も肺も胃も腸も片っ端から壊れる
細胞も全部もう混乱して
もう それで健康はもう崩れてしまう
それでこの怒りの人が幸福にならないということで
そういうふうに悪いことばっかりしているんだから
その人はすべての世界を敵に回していますから
すべてのものを敵の目で見ているんだから
その人も敵に敵の目で見られる
嫌な人として見られる
あの人と一緒には仕事を仕事をしたくないんだと
ものすごいうるさいんだと
あの人と一緒にいるとものすごいストレス溜まっちゃって
もうこちらまでダメになるんだと
ということは皆様にも経験あるでしょう
それでもいい仕事 才能があってもいい仕事は見つからない
人が優しい心で仕事をあげたっても
この人に才能あるんだから
じゃああの 何て言いますか
まあこうよ もう使ってみましょうと思っても
その人はあんまりにも激しい性格で
もういい仕事をしてこない
いい仕事はしません すべてダメになりますから
この怒りの性格あるならば
まあそれはもう待っていられません
すぐ直さなくちゃいけない
どうやって直しますかというと
すべての人々というのは不完全であって
すべてのものは不完全であって
もう完璧に自分ももう不完全なものだと
おおらかな心で 優しい心で
もう認めてあげることなんです
厳密主義 完璧主義 そんなものはありえない話だと
くだらない妄想概念だと捨てて楽になること
肩の力抜くこと まあ例えば部屋の中でとかね
まあまあ私はもう結構人の性格はまあ見る癖がありますけど
まあ性格を読むためには
まあ別にその人と話さなくたってもね
ちょっとしたこと見ればもうすぐ性格わかるんですね
ちょっと微かな体の動きを見たら
もう全部読まれてるんです
心でしか心体は動かせませんだから
これ隠せないんです 自分の性格は
隠してると思ってるんですけど
みんな じゃあ皆様自分
試しにご自分の服を見てください
それそれ違うでしょ？色ではなくて
この服の違うものを見るんですね
服はこのその服なりに綺麗にあります
あるいはちょっとガタガタになってるかと
新しく見えるか ちょっと古臭く見えるかと
それぞれ皆様の服を見てください
それで性格読めるんです
すごい悪いことなんですけど
まあ悪いこと そんなもんなんです
仏教の仏教にはもう秘密ないんだからね
全部見えているというか
見えているんです 例えば服自体は古いかもしれませんよ
古くてもすごく新しいもので見えるとこあるんです
それはその人の性格なんです
そこでもう買っても二回しか着てないかもしれませんだけど
ちょっとこれはもうよく着てる着ている服ではないかというふうに感じるものもあるんです
その人の性格 どこを見てもそれは表れるんです
まあそういうことで このヴィパッサナー瞑想でちゃんとサティを入れてやってくださいというのは
サティを入れるとそれも見えるんですね
すごく上品に 丁寧に立派な方のように見えちゃうんです
それからそれを続くと
我々はもともとどんな性格であろうとそんな関係なく
性格はもうきちんといい方向に直ってしまっちゃうんです
そういうことで 僕らは瞑想指導するときでも
人のあなたどういう人ですか？何食べてるんですか？どんなそんなあんまり個人的なことを聞かない
それはまあどうでもいいんです
これ実践すればもうきちんと直りますからね
いちいち人の個人的な相談ですか
カウンセリングを受けたりとかね
そういうことはもうする必要ない
みんななんか不親切だなと思うかもしれませんだけど
別にそこまでしなくたって
もう二 三週間で治るもんだからね
別に自分の弱いところやらね
いけないところやら そんな人にぶち明けなくたっても
人にばれる以前に治ればいいんだから
治せばいいんだから 僕らの指導方法ではそういう立場を取っているんです
別にあなたはどんな問題で悩んでるんですか？とかね
そんなことは別に私はちゃんと聞いてくれなかったとか
腹が立ったりする必要はないんです
別に私に言う必要もないし
この方法さえ実践すれば
自分の性格はきちんと直していきます
問題はない じゃあ そういうことで
怒りの世界 怒りとちょっと変わった形で
この嫉妬というものが生まれてくる
嫉妬も怒りなんです 嫉妬っていうのはもう他人に対する生まれるものなんですね
まあわかりやすい嫉妬っていうのは
やっぱり他人がうまくいったらすごくショックを受けちゃうんですね
自分の同級生であろうが
会社で一緒にいる仲間であろうが
例えば一緒に仕事 一緒に会社に入った人が二人がいて
まあそれで一人が特別に
あの 何て言いますか プロモーション
何て言いますか 日本語で
えっ 昇進 あっ 昇進 特別にもう昇進しました
させていただいた 会社から
そういう風に一緒に入った人はいきなり何か自分のことを惨めに感じちゃうんですね
あるいは自分と一緒にいた仲間は同じ学校出て同じ教育を受けているのに
一人が外国で仕事に派遣されたんだと思っちゃったら
なんとなくそういう場合は嫉妬と言うんですね
女性の方々は自分の一つのアクセサリーとしてそういうのをよく実践していますけど
嫉妬することっていうのは
で だからといってそれが男にないということは全くそういうことではなくて
男性女性関係なく 仏教っていうのは性別は関係ないんだから
もう誰にもあることなんですね
この嫉妬の場合は 自分が惨めに感じちゃう
不幸に感じちゃう それも怒りなんです
あの人はいいですね こうこうなってとかね
いろんな面で嫉妬する
それもついちゃったらもううまくいかない
なぜならば 世の中の人が幸福になればなるほど
この人はどんどんどんどん暗くなって暗くなって
小さくなってダメになっちゃいますから
自分で何もしなくてもいいんです
必ず不幸になってしまっちゃうんです
嫉妬すると 一緒にいた仲間が頑張って仕事を成功すると
この人はどんどんダメになっちゃう
自分のお友達の人はものすごい良いところにお嫁に行っちゃったら
この人にはもう見つかる相手がなくなってしまっちゃうとか嫉妬して
ですから ものすごい危ない性格なんです
なぜならば 何のことなく嫉妬ある人はどんどん不幸になるんです
自分が何もしなくてもいいんです
なぜならば どうせ世の中の人々は頑張っているんだから
もう成功している人々はもういくらでもいるんだから
それ十分なんです 自分の地獄を作るために
だからバカバカらしい
でもすごいバカバカらしいんです
でも嫉妬する人嫉妬するでしょ
それでも それも怒りと同じですから
すごい体も壊れます まあわかる
そこら辺で説明はもうその説明を終えますけどね
もし嫉妬する方々はどうするべきかというと
嫉妬を治るために やっぱり頑張って相手の幸福を喜ぶこと
ああ 良かったんではないかと心から感じるようにしてください
それで治るんです 私にできなかったんだから
それは別にどうったことないのではないかと
その人でも幸福になったらいいんじゃないか
私の友達でしょうと それは私に対しても自慢になるんじゃないかと
私と一緒に学校に勉強した仲間の一人がいて
あの人 あいつは今アメリカでこの会社で社長になってるんだと
この自分の会社で という風に言えばいいんです
たまに電話でもして もう休みにアメリカに飛んできますからね
ちゃんと私の面倒見てくれとかね
そういう部分ですごく
あの いわゆる相手の幸福を心から喜ぶ
自分の幸福にしまっちゃう
例えば女性二人で一人がすごいいいところにと
幸福なところにお嫁に行ったならば
自分にはもう自分に気に入ってる相手はもう普通の人間だと
そしたらそれに嫉妬するんじゃなくて
自分には立派な仲間がいるんだと
自分の旦那には贅沢してくることはできませんだけど
たまに友達のところに行ってすごい贅沢してもらうとか
自分の旦那は全然アクセサリーなんかは買ってくれませんだけど
友達 学校の仲間だからね
言って ちょっとネックレスでも貸してくれませんかと
それを貸してもらって
自分もどこかに行く時はそれをつけてもらうとか
別にパーティーに行ったところで誰も聞きませんよ
これ このネックレスをあなた誰から貸してくれたものですか？誰も聞きません
よく似合うんだったら
よく似合いますねとかね
言うだけで終わりますから
問題ないんです ですから
人の幸福っていうのは
結局自分の幸福に回すことはもう幸福の道であって
嫉妬するのはあんまりにもバカバカらしい自分の自己破壊の道になっちゃうんです
それパーリ語でイッサの反対の言葉はムディターというんです
この慈悲の瞑想で生きとし生けるものの願うことは叶います
叶えられますようにと願うのはムディターなんです
人々の願うことを叶ったとしても
自分には何の関係もないのではないかという嫉妬的な怒りのことを考えていけません
そうすると自分がダメになってしまっちゃうんです
誰であろうが何か成功しちゃったら
私たちも喜びはいいんです
分かりやすく言えば 日本人の一人がオリンピックで金メダル取ったら日本人みんな喜びますから
そんな感じなんです その人は自分で頑張って
もうメダルを取って それで自分の人生も出来上がりますけど
私たちには全然関係ないというのは関係ないんです
一円もくれませんだけど
でも我々もそれで喜びを感じる
ああ 日本はメダル取ったと
それはどんなものにもその感情を付ければいいでしょうに
広げればいいでしょうに
自分の隣の人々 周りの人々
付き合ってる人々の幸福を見て
それは本当に心からお祝いしてあげる
祝福してあげる 楽しがってあげる
それで人生は幸福になるし
もうこの悪い嫉妬の感情は消えちゃう
マッチュリヤっていうのはそちらの反対で
自分の幸福を他人に行き渡るのをものすごく嫌がっちゃうんです
ケチ的な考え方なんですね
これ ケチとも言いにくい性格ですけど
自分 まあ小さい時から見えるんです
子供の世界見たってね
自分の本を他の兄弟でも触ったら怒るし
自分のベッドに自分の弟か上の兄弟が乗っちゃったら
もうそれに怒る それ私のベッドではないかとか
自分の部屋に来るな 入るなとか
いちいち喧嘩したりとかね
そういうふうな性格はもう成長しちゃったら
もうマッチュリになってしまうんだ
それはすごく暗いんですね
その場合は 自分が惨めというよりは
自分がいろいろなものを持っている
その持っているものは
他の人々は共有するのは嫌なんです
それでいいんじゃないかと思うかもしれません
いいわけじゃないんです
我々は何のために成功するんですか？そこを分かってないんです
人々が 何のために人生を成功して幸福になろうと思いますか？本当はそれは社会のためなんです
社会から馬鹿にされるならば
あなたすごく金持ちだからあっち行けと
こっち来るなと 結婚式にも紹介しないならば
誰が金持ちになるんです
それだったら お金たくさんあると
みんなによく思ってもらって
いろんな結婚式やいろんなところにも
何て言いますか 歓迎されて
認めてもらって あれ 結婚の間に座る人
何て言いますか あのね
仲人 仲人として頼まれてというと
それで幸福を感じるんです
銀行口座の数字がいっぱい
もうゼロがいっぱい貯まってるんだということで
別に幸福を感じるわけじゃないんです
そこで例えば人がすごい立派なお家を建てたんだと
そのうちには犬猫 1匹でも入ってはいけませんと
あっちこっちから片っ端からこのいろいろ道具なんですか
いろいろありますからね
このセキュリティもインストゥルメントいろいろありますし
そんなものをつけちゃって
猫でも入っちゃったらもうものすごくアラームが鳴いたりとかね
もう人間も誰も一人も呼んでくれない
友達にも接待しないと
そのうちはいくら大きく建っても
いくら高価な家であろうとも
ただのお化け屋敷になっちゃうでしょ
すごい不幸になるんです
みんなに嫌われちゃう
それで社会から見放されたら
我々の人生はそれで終わりと
何にもできません 例えば
子供がもう親と喧嘩して結婚しましたと
親に破門されたと うちに来るなと言われたんだと
それでその子は腹が立って
もう自分で生活しているんだけど
やっぱり親もすごく悩んでるんですね
その子供も自分で子供作っているんだけど
やっぱりまあ親に嫌われてるっていうことは
もうやっぱりすごい自分の人生にとってはなんかすごい黒い
もう点灯してもううろうろしているんですね
別に親から何かもらうわけでも何でもないかもしれません
ただ親に怒られたという
だからずっとそれが残るんです
自分には子供人が出て
もうよく仕事をして もう家庭として成功していたっても
やっぱり両側の親にはもう破門されているんだと
それである日 もし親が許してくれちゃったら
それすごい幸福なんですね
許してくれたんだからって
別に何かもらうわけではないんだけど
やっぱりまあいいよ お前ら頑張るんだから許してあげますよというその一言葉がものすごい幸福なんです
それからものすごく楽に生きていられる
ですから 社会に認めてもらうこと
社会に見放され 見放されないことも人間の幸福なんです
このマッチュリエがあったら
そこは消えちゃう 社会から追い出される
一切があっても社会から追い出される
で ダメになる じゃあ番目に行きます
あ マッチュリの反対のこと
やっぱりみんなと 分かち合うというかね
自分の持っている才能やら物っていうのはみんなと共有するように
自分が英語できてすごいしっかりしているならば
英語必要な人にはそれはまあ役に立つようにしてあげる
そのための英語でしょうに
例えばもう外国人の人が来て
あれ日本人と喋らなくちゃいけない
自分知ってる友達なんですけど
その友達は全然英語わからない
自分が英語わかる それで友達ちょっと友達に頼まれたら
まあちょっともうなんか通訳してくれませんか？と言ったら
私はすごい苦労して もう何年かもう寝ないで勉強して勉強して
すごくお金かかって英語を勉強してたのに
あなたにもう何のための通訳するんでしょうと思ったら
そのバカバカらしい考え方なんですね
自分が一人で頑張って英語知識得たかもしれません
やっぱり友達に通訳してあげると
そこでやっと幸福を感じるんです
だから我々のものはやっぱりみんなのものだと
社会のためにあるんだと思って
いわゆる何の心ですかね
それは で まあ仏教用語ではそれは布施と言うんだけどね
まあその その気持ちで生きていなくちゃいかない
それも幸福の道になるんですね
ものをみんなと分かち合って生活する
それはマッチュリの反対
じゃあ番目のクックッチェ
クックッチェ クックッチェというのは後悔
後悔も怒りなんです 後悔する場合はこういう風に後悔するんです
例えば自分に悪いこと
自分が悪いことをしたならば
ああ悪いことをしてしまったと
ああ失敗してしまったと
で 後悔する いいことをできなかったならば
いいことをできなかったと
若い時は勉強できなかったと
と後悔する 悪いことをしたと後悔する
いいことをできなかったと後悔する
どっちにしても過去について後悔する
その後悔することは またものすごい猛烈な猛毒なんです
全てなくなってしまっちゃうんです
なぜならば この後悔するときは
自分がアクティブじゃないんです
行動しないんです 後悔しているんだから
この活動力ですか 心と体の活動力はものすごくすぐ止まっちゃうんです
皆さんは自分が後悔した時
自分のことを思い出してみてください
その時は何もやらないでしょう
あ 失敗しましたと思うとやる気が消えちゃうんですね
何か仕事を頼まれた ちょっとした勉強が必要になる
その時はやっぱり勉強しておけばよかったなと思っちゃうということは
今の仕事をやりたくなくなってるんです
やれないと思ってるんです
ですから アクティブでなくなっちゃうんです
活発的なこの我々の生き方は消えちゃう
活動力を止まる だから活動したいという心のエネルギーがいきなり止まる
毒なんですね 後悔っていうのは
そこでその毒 そのウイルスが入っていると
危ないことっていうのは後悔しようとすると
もう後悔して死に死にほどの失敗は人間にあるんです
ずっと我々がやったことは片っ端から思い出してみると
一つもうまくいったっていうことは出てこないと思いますよ
うまくいっても何かまたちょっと何かあるんですね
例えば会社を作って ものすごく頑張って
もう一応もう軌道に乗って大きく成功しましたと
あ 万々歳だと思わないんです
いろんな自分が悪いことやらきついことやら
よくないことやら その会社をちゃんと成功するためにやったことをいくらでも出てくるんです
嫌な人に会ったことやら
ひどい目にあったことやら
それで人間やることは一つも完璧じゃないんだから
いつでも後悔しようと思えばいくらでもあるんです
そこで後悔することによって
我々は活動しないために言い訳をするんです
すごく暗いエネルギーなんです
猛毒といえば猛毒なんです
仏教で後悔のために何を言うんですか？なんで後悔してはいけないんですか？何か人がすごい悪いことをしたんだと
だから後悔するのは当たり前ではないかと
じゃあ後悔して何になるんですかね？何にもならない
ただ活動力なくなるだけ
それで後悔すればするほど
これを膨張するんです
この悪いエネルギーが
それもっと危ないんです
どんどん膨張する さらに後悔してしまう
大変な精神的な病気になってしまう
ですから 後悔の反対はこの
明るくすることなんですね
例えば人があんたすごい失敗しましたんではないかと
そうなんです すごい失敗しました
こういうことでバカなことをやっちゃったんだと
それだけ 平気 平気ではなくて
ものすごい堂々と正直な気持ちでそれを認めればいいんです
だからあんた恥ずかしくはないんですか？と
もう恥ずかしいんですけど
まあやったことだからしょうがないでしょうと
それだけ 別にじゃあこれから気をつけますかとか
じゃあこれからしっかりやりなさいと
もう余計な説法は今人はしますけど
そんな必要ないんです
じゃああんた今失敗しましたからね
これからちゃんと気をつけなさいと
会社では上司とか言うでしょ
あの言葉余計なんです
本人が自分の失敗を認めたならば
なぜならば なぜかというと
私はこの仕事は失敗しますとと思って仕事をする人はいませんよ
料理をすると 今度はもう大失敗の料理作りますと思って料理作る人がいるんですか？いない
誰であろうか きちんとやろうという気持ちは常にあるんです
で 余計なところで 学校の先生たちやら会社の上司やら
みんないちいちいちいち言ってるんです
だからみんなストレス溜まっちゃってうまくいってないんです
だから余計な説教 説法するのはやめた方がいいんです
人は誰でももう失敗したいんだと
まずいことをやりたいと思ってないんです
行動するとそういう結果になるだけ
でもそれはちゃんと理解しないと
次から次へまた失敗しますから
正直に認めちゃおう 明るい心で
例えばなかなか男性に好かれない女性がいるならば
それをごまかす 全然私のことをあなた方は全然もう気にしてくれないねとか
何て言いますか モテない女で悪かったねとか
そういう風に言われるようになっちゃったら
その人はものすごい抜群に明るいんです
そんな明るい人を捨てるバカな男はいないよ
この人をいるとあまりにも明るくて
もう何でもうまくいきますよと
だからこの後悔だけはやめれば
もう後悔やめれば それによってもう人間というのは幸福になるんです
後悔 この 4つを仏教では罪だと言っているんです
悪だと ですから 知らないうちにいっぱい悪をしていることにもなるんです
なんで悪だ 罪だと言ってるんですか
仏教の悪の概念 罪の概念というのは
この幸福にならない原因
全部罪だ 悪だと言ってるんです
この地獄に落ちるんだということでもないんです
地獄にも落ちるかもしれませんだけど
今世においても不幸になる道は罪の道なんです
最悪の道なんです ということは
皆様方が頑張って幸福な家庭を作ると
それも仏教的な正しい道徳的な生き方を実現したことなんです
会社でちゃんと仕事をして
自分の仕事をちゃんと果たして
もう問題ない人生で生きているというならば
その人は仏教を知らなくても道徳的な生き方をやっているんです
それで見てください 日本の社会を見ても
全然宗教に興味も何もない人々はいっぱいいるし
でもちゃんと仕事をして
ちゃんと家族を養って
ちゃんと子供たちを教育させて
一人前にしてあげて で
勉強したいものをちゃんと勉強して
もうそれから何でしたっけ
趣味がいろいろあるならば
そういうものもやって
で 最終的にあなたの人生どうですか
私は別に死ぬのは怖くないんだと
大変幸福な生き方でしたと
明るく死ぬでしょ そういう明るく死ぬ人々は
決して悪いところに生まれ変わることもないんです
で 仏教の人が出て あんた仏教を信じてないんだからダメですよと言ったっても
それは大きなお世話で
生き方は正しかったんだから
人間として その正しい結果はどうせ得られるんです
そういうこと ですから
このいい行いをしようと
という仏教で言ってますけど
ただ家の仕事をすることもいい行いなんです
ちゃんと料理を作ったり
掃除洗濯したりして みんなの面倒を見てあげたりすることも素晴らしい行いなんです
ですから そこはきちんと仏教では認めていることで
幸福になる道は善の道で
不幸になる道は不善の悪の道であるということで
まあどうしますか 時間になりましたけど
またいっぱいあることはあるんです
で 今日の話 本当はもう半分じゃない
四分の一なんです なぜかというと
この私は今までずっと喋ったのはこのコントロールできる部分
これからコントロールできないところに行きたかったんだけど
そうするとこの体の内臓のことやらね
この血管の問題で それいろいろこれもコントロールできるようになる方法もありますけどね
そこで終わり？ いえいえ
時間はいいですけど